well cnn's jim acosta admitting the
media
is going to go easy on joe biden he told
the atlantic quote
i don't think the press should be trying
to whip up the biden presidency and turn
it into
must-see tv in a contrived way end quote
wasn't that rich from him
that of course comes as a complete
opposite of what acosta did
for the last four years watch this
organization
not can you give us a chance you are
attacking our news organization
can you give us a chance to ask a
question sir
david by the president's tone thank you
president's tone towards the press
obviously is not helpful
what i'm asking you the statue of
liberty jim has always been let me ask
you a question hope to the world
for people to send jim do you believe to
this country
mr president if i may ask one question
are you worried that's enough
that's it
that could that tape could go on and on
and on now the media
is about to go into hibernation for the
next four years and take a nap
as they did with the obama
administration in my opinion
now jessica why shouldn't the media be
equally
as aggressive against a biden
administration as a trump administration
but we all know it's not even
close and jim acosta even admits out
loud they're not going to do that
well last time i checked jim acosta
doesn't speak for the white house
press corps and mass and jim acosta has
a very special relationship with
president trump as was just
magnified by those clips that you showed
um i imagine though that there are a lot
of reporters who do have hard-hitting
questions and hopefully joe biden and
kamala harris will be open to them i
have always been an advocate for that
from everything from policy positions to
talking about hunter biden
i think it's important to put it all out
there but i think that we would be
remiss if we didn't discuss the fact
that president trump
continued to go back to outlets that
were favorable to him and when he
actually sat down with tough
interviewers
with leslie stahl or chris wallace he
was reduced almost to tears
he brought him big books of fake papers
chris wallace he was defending some iq
test
that he took where he had to identify
something as an elephant
and he said that it was like the
toughest test in the world
um that's not a man who likes to be
pushed yeah and joe
didn't didn't even come on fox news
because he couldn't take the
the pressure i mean chris wallace works
for us
to be fair to be fair i think the press
proved where they stood on many of the
issues when they concealed
the hunter biden story it is true that
the justice department didn't make an
announcement
but it was all it was leaked to them and
they decided not to
report it i don't think the american
people want the press
to pretend like they're unbiased but
they do expect them to be fair
i think a lot of the criticism of what
we saw from a lot of the president
was the fact that it seemed like the
media despised
his supporters it is one thing to
criticize the president
and take him on i don't like many of the
politicians which is why i don't go to
their parties or anything like that
but the fact that they wouldn't cover
the stories that matter to the audience
half of the country i think showed a lot
of where they stand so yes there will be
a return to the norm lisa we got to get
your
comments real quick yeah what kind of
ice cream having joe those are the
questions
those are the questions that joe biden
got on the campaign trail and that's
because
we don't have a press corps anymore the
mainstream meter a bunch of left-wing
partisan hacks and the best thing about
the past four years
is that president trump has gotten them
to drop
their cloak and show us the partisan
hacks that they are and i think it's so
much healthier as a society
for everyone to know where these people
stand they don't have the interests of
the american people at heart
they have the interest of propagating
left-wing
propaganda while trying to hurt
republicans and that's been on the full
display
for the fast four years everyone's eyes
are open
degan what's your view on this is jim
acosta
so thick-witted and pumpkin-headed that
he doesn't realize that trump losing is
the
worst thing that could happen for his
career
he's not good on tv the only reason
people would watch him is because folks
hated maybe trump
as much as jim acosta hated trump
the only thing that would make him less
appealing on television if
he talked like christian amanpour as you
perfectly well know i'm a journalist and
a reporter
and i followed the facts and there have
never been any issues in
terms of corruption as christian
amanpour said about
hunter baden and joe biden yeah i i
listen
donald trump should have won awards for
his openness and transparency and
answering every question that's coming
his way
and shame on joe biden and kamala harris
is even worse they just don't answer
anything and they need to be asked hard
questions all right the